what's going on guys this is Rob and I'm
like 99 sure that Avengers King Dynasty
is basically going to be Avengers
forever by a different name so we're
gonna cover that story right it might
also have a little dash of Exiles world
tour right just a little pinch thrown in
there for seasoning right just for
flavor but still uh we're gonna cover
Avengers forever this is the original
from 1998 yes Marvel's doing one from
2022. it's okay so here's the thing uh
this story basically picks up with a
couple things that we need to explain
the first is the Supreme intelligence
and the second is Rick Jones so the idea
behind Rick Jones and really seemingly
the whole reason why this story is
happening actually takes place in the
Prelude to the beginning of Avengers
forever which is basically a guy by the
name of Jones Ricard who literally just
launches an invasion against another
world freezes everybody in time and then
sends his forces which are kind of
modeled after the Avengers to slaughter
everybody so he literally kills
everybody while they're frozen in time
and they can't move and he does it
because they had some kind of a
rebellion there the way he's able to do
this is by utilizing something called
the Destiny force and we'll talk about
that here in a second but focusing on
the Supreme intelligence literally when
Kurt Busick started riding the Avengers
in like issue number seven there was a
group called The Lunatic Legion which
were just these crazy Cree members who
were residing on Earth for a while they
ended up grabbing the Supreme
intelligence who was at the center of
the earth and then brought him to the
blue area of the Moon where there's
oxygen and then they intended to like
rebuild or bring back the the cree
Empire by turning humans in decree was
it a good story no not really but that's
why the Supreme intelligence is here on
the blue area of the Moon the reason why
that matters is because the Avengers
bring Rick Jones to the Supreme
intelligence to see if those Supreme
intelligence can't figure out what's
going on with Rick Jones the reason for
this goes all the way back to the 1970s
with a story that Marvel wrote called
the crease scroll war and this is
exactly what it sounds like a war
between the cree and the Scrolls the way
the conflict came to an end is that the
Supreme intelligence woke up the powers
woke up the destiny Force inside of Rick
Jones which allowed Rex Jones to
basically end the conflict and then
those Powers were taken away by the
Supreme intelligence again but the war
ultimately ended the destiny Force
itself is like this ridiculously
enigmatic thing in Marvel Comics that's
really more of a plot device than
anything else the way it played out with
Rick Jones is that back in the day in
Marvel Comics the idea was that Rick
Jones was very similar to Bruce Banner
and the Incredible Hulk and the sense
that Rick Jones was fused with Captain
Marvel of the creep so when Marvel
wasn't running around and doing his
thing he was Rick Jones Rick Jones would
turn into Marvel and then he would be a
superhero literally he would slap his
Mega bands together and like that's how
that would work right like Wonder Woman
hitting her bracelets together but doing
more than blocking bullets so the thing
about this is that the the destiny force
of Rick Jones would intermittently pop
up here and there and the destiny Force
represents like the sum total of what
humanity is capable of right like the
greatness of what Humanity can achieve
manifests in the form of a source of
power that Rick Jones can use that's
what Jones Rick hard was using at the
beginning of the story and that's what
Rick Jones can somewhat channel of
course Jones Ricard has his own
character and we'll talk about him here
in a little while but the Avengers bring
uh ring Rick Jones to the Supreme
intelligence is based on the idea that
the Supreme intelligence can understand
Rick Jones on a very fundamental level
but of course the Supreme intelligence
tells the Avengers Leaf right like if
you guys want me to check this guy out
and figure out what's going on with him
I need to do it in privacy without you
guys standing around and watching
because you're a bunch of weirdos and so
ultimately The Avengers end up leaving
here this leads to the arrival of an
enigmatic character that we don't really
know anything about who's just kind of
watching these things unfold and is kind
of talking to this supreme intelligence
about how Rick Jones and his use of the
destiny force is moving Humanity towards
a precipice where they will kind of
evolve into the next state of evolution
to a higher state of being and in turn
achieve an incredible level of power the
problem here is that there are those out
there that will not want to see this
happen and this comes in the form of
immortus making his move now let's talk
about a mortise and came to conqueror
and ramatut and iron lad and all that
kind of stuff let's clear all this up so
the way this worked is that in the 30th
Century you had a guy named Nathaniel
Richards Nathaniel Richards grew bored
with his timeline and decided to go back
and conquer the world by conquering
ancient Egypt he called himself Rama tut
the Fantastic Four realized what he was
doing traveled back to the past and then
defeated Rama Tut that led to him having
to go back to the 30th Century he ended
up overshooting the 30th century and
landed in the 31st century and so
because Humanity was really primitive
surrounded by advanced technology he
seized control of the technology and
then conquered the 31st century and
changed his name to Kane the Conqueror
following that he had a whole bunch of
different campaigns where he was calling
himself The Scholar Centurion and he was
trying to defeat the Avengers and
different things like that and he always
lost during this time one of the things
he did is he visited his younger self
and he told him you're gonna have to
make decisions X Y and Z in order to
ensure that you become me his younger
self didn't want to do that he wanted to
become his own superhero so that led to
his younger self calling himself iron
lad now as for immortus that's explained
in this story so we'll get there soon
enough so what ends up happening here
kind of getting back to our story where
you have basically Rick Jones just kind
of sitting there in the presence of the
Supreme intelligence what ends up
happening is that immortus makes his
move by freezing time in that area like
literally freezing time all over the
place like the Earth itself everything's
frozen and then he in turn sends out his
his main Force Tempest right this guy
that basically does the bidding of a
mortise when he doesn't want to get his
hands dirty Tempest shows up here and
tries to kill Rick Jones but in the
middle of that a Time bubble of forms
that actually allows Rick Jones to wake
up from being frozen in time only for
tempest to realize King the Conqueror is
there and Kane the Conqueror is the one
who created that time bubble in the
first place now the whole reason why
this happens and even the whole reason
why immortus is doing what he's doing is
not something that we're readily aware
of at the moment instead what ends up
going on is that Tempest tries to
destroy Kang and Kang destroys Tempest
but following that immortus basically
says because Tempest was constructed out
of limbo all King has done is literally
create a portal and that basically
allows immortus Army which is called the
army of the ages to pour in to where
Kane the Conqueror is at now the army of
the ages is quite literally an army of
people from just different points in
time so this Army is composed of Samurai
and knights from the Dark Ages and
conquistadors and the whole nine yards
right even like World War one and World
War II soldiers right just people who by
whatever Manner and whatever means have
sworn allegiance to immortus and in turn
gone forward and done their own thing to
compare this to the MCU in the trailer
and Ant-Man quantumania at the time
we're recording this video when
basically Kang tells Scott Lang he can
give him more time and presumably Scott
Lang temporarily enters the service of
King imagine that service never ended
and that's how the army of the Aegis
works right literally he just ensnares
you in and keeps you there now Kang
initially wages a one-man war against
the entirety of the army of the ages but
it's a war of attrition King can't fight
them all forever and so as Rick Jones
starts to wake up King makes this last
ditch plea and says use your powers your
destiny Force whatever it is and find a
way for us to get out of this and so
Rick Jones not fully realizing what he's
doing ends up snatching Avengers out of
different points in time and the
Avengers being timed his place emerge
here right they literally arrive in this
location that's why this is important
and that's why I say that Avengers Kang
Dynasty is basically going to be
Avengers forever by a different name
instead of the Avengers just being
plucked Out of Time Imagine they're
plucked out of time and from other
realities and that's really how that
works so it's entirely possible that we
may actually get the Tom Cruise Superior
Iron Man but of course following this
these Avengers are familiar with each
other in the sense that they recognize
each other but they don't know each
other because they're not all from the
same point in time and so the result of
this is that they do temporarily Ally
themselves alongside Kang who literally
tells them I'm not your enemy I'm your
friend at least here in the moment we
have to find a way to destroy the army
of the ages or at the very least get
Rick Jones out of here because as long
as he's here immortus will find a way to
destroy him and it's inevitable that
immortus will kill him so the only way
to keep Rick Jones alive is to take him
outside of time to remove him from the
time stream which is the one place that
immortus simply just can't go and so
what this does is it leads to the
Avengers sort of pairing together
working together and of course defeating
the army of the ages just long enough
for immortus to realize that with the
aid of the Avengers and the fact that
it's almost like fighting an army of
kings that this is a stalemate there's
no way he can conceive probably went and
so ultimately he pulls his forces out
they all withdraw and then Kane the
Conqueror basically tells them get Rick
Jones out of here right like find a way
to get him out of here and Kane the
Conqueror ultimately ends up leaving now
this leads to the arrival of the cloaked
figure who was talking to the Supreme
intelligence that we didn't fully know
who it was and he basically Reveals His
identity as being Libra now the funny
thing about this is that Libra doesn't
matter and he never really has uh he was
a character from like back in the day in
Marvel Comics when you basically had a
group of criminals called the Zodiac for
the longest time he was filled at least
under the Roy Thomas days he was built
as a guy who could potentially be maybe
a credible threat to the Avengers kind
of that's one thing to understand about
Marvel back in the day right back in
like the 60s 70s and kind of in the 80s
before Chris Claremont took over the
took over the scene with like his X-Men
run and started introducing like
villains that were really interesting
and compelling it was by and large just
villains of the week right there were a
lot of things going on behind the scenes
and you'll find out what that is with
the comments explained podcast yes it's
on its way so the thing about this is
that Libra was just a guy who was there
the way this is being reworked by Kurt
Busick is it's saying that Libra despite
his criminal activities was more
interested in like balance and he was
more interested in gaining knowledge and
that kind of stuff and that's why he's
here more as a guide than anything else
but again because the Avengers are kind
of boxed into a corner they don't fully
understand what's going on with this
whole situation and all they know is
that Kang who was a one-time enemy has
now turned Ally that they basically need
to to do what it is that this guy says
right because it seemingly their best
chance to make it out of all of this in
one piece and so leaving the current
timeline and stepping outside of time
they're now outside of the multi or
really out of the outside of the
universe itself but we also end up
getting this sort of breakdown of who
these different members of The Avengers
are of course you basically have two
Hank pens running around the one that
was plucked out of time is the Hank Pym
who is basically going crazy back in the
day when he was calling himself
yellowjacket but the other part here is
we're actually introduced to Songbird
now Songbird was at one point a villain
specifically she became big in the
Thunderbolts she ended up reforming and
becoming a superhero but nobody qua is
really quite sure what to make of her
but they're all kind of just plucked out
of these different moments and there's
no real Rhyme or Reason to it right it's
not like what we've seen in more recent
stories coming out of Marvel where
they're plucked from like the moment
when they're about to die right it's
just one of those things where they were
just sort of snatched up because Rick
Jones just grabbed them in a panic but
the fact that they're all here even with
Captain America himself his story is
intriguing he was plucked out at a point
when he was facing off against secret
Empire and that was a story that Marvel
wrote where Captain America actually
ended up chasing down number one who was
the leader of secret Empire that old
team actually didn't use names they used
numbers to basically differentiate a
kind of ranking system but one of the
really the leader of the secret Empire
had actually infiltrated the US
government and was working to bring the
US government down that was the
inspiration that Nick Spencer used for
the secret Empire story that he wrote 40
or 50 years later in more recent years
that focused on Captain America the
thing about this is that number one
actually ended up offered himself
because he didn't want to be taken
prison which is kind of how the members
of secret Empire function but Captain
America was painfully disillusioned with
the combination of the United States
government and just being a superhero in
general that led to him kind of stepping
away from the role of Captain America
for a time and then eventually coming
back but the overall gist of this is
that the team is hodgepodge right
they're all just kind of thrown together
in an impossible situation and no one
quiet is quite sure what's supposed to
be happening here and no one really even
understands what's going on here and so
what ends up going on here is that where
the questions asked where do they go and
what do they do because they can't just
hang out outside of Time Forever they
end up Consulting Rick Jones because
he's kind of the decision maker if for
no other reason than the fact that
they're the ones that are supposed to be
keeping him safe and so the result of
this is that Rick Jones decides that if
Kane the Conqueror was able to protect
him even if only for a moment against
the forces of immortus then what safer
place to go than to go to chronopolis
where Kane the Conqueror resides the
problem is that once they get there they
end up finding that immortus is already
attacking chronopolis because in his
mind it was the most logical place for
them to go to now some of this also has
to do with the fact that because Kane
the Conqueror sits outside of time he
sees all time simultaneously but at the
same time there are a few things going
on behind the scenes that actually keep
him from being able to know exactly
what's supposed to happen and so that's
why time traveled to a degree in this
story is kind of used as a plot device
more so than anything else but the
Avengers showing up here to chronopolis
they're able to kind of fend off some of
the forces of uh of immortus but the
whole idea is to actually get Rick Jones
inside of chronopolis and decaying
directly in order to figure out what to
do here the result of this is that as
they finally get inside where Kang is
Kenya is actually in the process of
effectively evacuating that his forces
here facing off against the mortis is
really more of a stopgap measure he
doesn't really have any intention of
saying like sure we can win this he
knows he can't because the forces of a
mortis are endless they're literally
plucked from the time stream and they
could stretch on forever so again a war
of attrition that's why he's doing
things like he rebuilt thinks that he
used previously to travel back in time
as Rama Tut he's actually kind of
rebuilt that and he's moving it to a
safer location but as the Avengers
arrive here the response of Kang is this
is the last place you should have come
to right like it makes the most sense
that a mortise in an effort to keep me
from interfering would strike at the one
place that I use the most but the other
part of this is he says chronopolis is a
very particular place a very important
place when it comes to time travel and
the reason why is because traveling back
and forth through time and traveling
into the past does not allow you to
change the past right so for example
Cain the Conqueror cannot travel back
into the past and destroy all the
Avengers before they ever became
Avengers right he can't do that and then
guarantee his rise to power what that
would do is it would create alternate
timelots say that he killed five
Avengers before they ever became
Avengers now you've got five different
timelines where each one of them never
became Avengers then you've got an
infinite number of timelines on how
those things could have played out based
on those Avengers not coming into
existence right so the result of this is
he tells Janet Van Dyne the only thing
that ever happens is that when you go
back and try to change the past you
create branching timelines and he says
that's the beauty of chronopolis
chronopolis allows me to travel back
into the past and actually modify the
past in order to affect the present day
and the future it's why a mortise is
attacking this place because at the core
of this place is literally what will
become the forever Crystal the source of
energy that powers the entirety of this
Citadel and if a mortise gets his hands
on it then a mortise can start wiping
out different universes across the
Multiverse he can just start ending
things right or just changing the past
and affecting everything else it allows
him complete and total Mastery over all
of the timelines and so while the
Avengers are able to enjoy a bit of
respite while they're here at
chronopolis meaning they can basically
experience some r r the fight's back on
again when amortis sends his forces in
yet again and so as they're facing off
against these guys that's when Kane
tells them this is a stopgap measure we
cannot hold immortus off forever
eventually he is going to overtake the
chronopolis and if Rick Jones is here
when that happens it's game over right
and so what it does is it leads to the
uh to The Avengers seizing control of
the Sphinx of Kang taking off into the
time stream while at the same time
immortus finally manages to break into
chronopolis and as he does he overpowers
Kane the Conqueror and then seizes the
heart of forever and then re-christens
it into the forever Crystal and what it
allows him to do is to literally take
the entire 31st Century where Kane the
Conqueror rules with chronopolis and
absorb everything into the forever
Crystal all beings who are present in
that location are now confined there the
issue is that immortus thought that the
Avengers and Rick Jones were still in
that vicinity once he realizes that's
not the case now it's a hunt fighting a
war on two fronts one part is immortus
going through and literally pruning the
time stream eradicating timelines that
don't need to exist the other part of it
is trying to find Rick Jones in The
Avengers because seemingly the level of
power Rick Jones has through the destiny
force is the one thing that can stand in
the way of immortus and his camp paint
now it's kind of ironic about this is
that as they're able to make their
escape Libra keeps kind of telling them
like we should do this or we should do
that we should consider trying to find a
way out but the funny thing here is that
Hawkeye just kind of lashes out at Libra
now of course Libra's response here is
man you're hurting my feelings and the
response of Hawkeye has almost heard a
lot more than that if you don't get out
of here right so ultimately he chases
off their guide they're quite literally
Flying Blind throughout the entirety of
the Multiverse and so what ends up
happening here is both Hank pims seize
control of the navigation systems for
the Sphinx and they pick up on the fact
that there are three chronal anomalies
taking place throughout the history of
the universe somebody's messing with
time in a significant way at three
points in time in the universe's history
and so this leads to the group splitting
into three separate groups in order to
investigate these particular points in
time now the first group to emerge is
the modern day Hank Pym along with
Captain America who show up in the 21st
century New York City right Manhattan
specifically and as they get there the
whole place is a wasteland right like
martians are waste to the entirety of
the area they're literally killing
everybody right like everybody's more or
less been destroyed what's funny about
this is this actually was inspired by
The War of the Worlds and so as they
make their way through there Captain
America's and of course Ant-Man are
fighting against some various forces
they're able to hold their own to a
degree but when there's a spot that's
open where Captain America is almost
taken out he's actually saved by the
Avengers of this timeline which
basically turns out to be led by black
panther but the other part about this is
this black panther here is actually
t'challa it's the real t'challa who's of
course older and he's a lot more
grizzled and hardened than he used to be
but what he basically explains is that
somewhere along the line a massive
conflict took place and the marches
started invading and like The Avengers
were basically killed so seeing Captain
America here takes him by surprise
because Steve Rogers is supposed to be
dead now Steve Rogers of course fesses
up right off the bat and says well I'm
not from this time stream home slice uh
I am from like back in the day now the
other group that comes together is
Hawkeye and the past Hank Pym along with
Songbird who end up in the old west now
the funny thing about this is songbird
knows how this whole situation plays out
and so what you end up coming up on is
like the two gun kid and these
characters who are basically older
characters of Marvel used to Kyle used
to publish way back in the day when like
Stan Lee was the one man show who is
basically creating everything and this
led to them basically focusing on like
Western Comics and things like that two
gun kids not really important he hasn't
been for a long time in Marvel Comics
but this is basically a point where Kang
is trying to conquer this part of
history in the 19th century songbirds is
kind of like all right look we gotta go
like we don't have time to face off
against Kang here besides I know how
this plays out some Avengers show up
here they defeat Kane the Conqueror he
goes back to his time and like the day's
safe so there really isn't anything for
us to do here so they end up basically
bailing out but when they get back to
where their time sphere is supposed to
be it's gone right somebody took it and
so the third group is genus Val also
known as the new Captain Marvel along
with Jana van Don we don't really need
to go to specifically in the genus Veil
he's kind of the roundabout son of
Marvel I want to say that he was created
right he was literally cloned from
Marvel but I'm not gonna swear to that
off the top of my head honestly I'm not
overly familiar with him because he
hasn't been relevant in Marvel Comics
for like 25 years but literally he's
just the new cosmic-powered Avenger
who's plucked out of time by Rick Jones
and was brought here right so it's not
overly important with this character the
thing about this and what's really kind
of crazy is where the story sort of goes
off the rails a little bit that Richard
Nixon is on the campaign Trail because
this is 1959 and uh Marvel realizes that
it's not actually Richard Nixon Dennis a
scroll pretending to be Richard Nixon
but what matters here is that where
genus Val initially goes to make a move
against basically Richard Nixon the vice
president of the United States
he goes to attack the guy knowing that
he's a scroll that Avengers end up
stepping in here now this Avengers team
they originally appeared in what if
Issue Number Nine back in March of 1978
they were actually uh an Avengers team
that was brought together by Jimmy Wu
and actually served as more of like a
presidential guard initially it dealt
with a villain named Yellow Claw who
tried to kidnap president Dwight
Eisenhower and take him out of course
the Avengers basically came together and
defeated him and saved the president and
following that they remained as kind of
a detail at this point in time they're
basically protecting Richard Nixon but
again they're not an overly important
team 3D man like the guy who's in the
weird looking get up he's okay right
he's he's interesting you have a few
recognizable characters here but none of
these guys are overly important right
pulling a page out of and really kind of
talking about the future of the MCU this
could be yet another Avengers team that
we've never seen before that exists out
there in the Multiverse so that's why
these kinds of things are really really
cool and they're really fascinating
because what you're dealing with here is
not only the uh the manipulation of time
but the jumping in and out of alternate
realities here now of course each one of
these groups has their own individual
stories and so focus on on this old what
if Avengers team meeting The Avengers
team that's currently trying to figure
out what's going on with these time
anomalies that the time Avengers we can
call them that in order to keep that
separation simple they basically reveal
that Richard Nixon's a scroll and that
the Avengers themselves just kind of
take the time Avengers at their work but
they also kind of say look I mean this
is sort of what's going on here
something you have to be aware of that
the idea of the Scrolls being here is to
literally sabotage the United States
space program that's the whole point in
order to keep humans from going into
space when they did but of course once
this Revelation comes out then the
Avengers tell the time Avengers okay
we're on your side we'll stop fighting
we gotta find a way to deal with Richard
Nixon now jumping back to the Avengers
in the west what they end up finding out
is that it was actually Kane the
Conqueror who at that point in time is
trying to conquer the 19th century and
has somehow become aware of the fact
that they're there he's the one that
stole their sphere so when they get back
there like a king hologram kind of
taunts them a little bit and then tries
to collapse the cave in songbirds able
to save them but that leaves to the
arrival of the gun Hawks right so you
basically have the black writer you've
got Reno Jones kid Cassidy right you
have these old western characters that
are here trying to help them out as best
they can and saying okay obviously Kane
the Conqueror is the guy who's the main
villain here let's deal with him and
then we'll find a way to get you guys
back to your normal time I mean they're
old western superheroes who are running
around with with revolvers like what are
they gonna do but the thing about this
and they kicker about all this is that
you have Hawkeye who's a massive fan of
like old westerns and he's a massive fan
of these guys right he's like I spent my
whole life reading about you studying
your history it's so fascinating to be
able to meet you you can't imagine how
impossible this is and when kid
Cassidy's like yeah man I mean it's a
cool experience Hawkeye says especially
because kid Cassidy was dead by 1873. so
that's what he realizes it's not kid
Cassidy it's somebody posing as kid
Cassidy and he tells the Avengers like
hit him right so literally it's just
like he takes out kid casting he's like
get him guys and like the Avengers and
snare these guys only for us to find out
yeah they're basically space Phantoms
and the space Phantoms are forces of
Immortals in the old school Comics there
was only one space Phantom that was ever
encountered as a as a kind of servant of
immortus what this shows is he's got a
whole host of them the bigger Point here
and the reason why this matters is
because it demonstrates immortus has
spies everywhere all over the place that
there's no way to know because the space
Phantoms are shape shifters so there's
no way to know if the person standing
next to you is a space Phantom or if
they're basically the person they've
always claimed to be and that's the
concern that they initially have when
you go back to the to the situation with
Richard Nixon that you've got the time
Avengers and you've got the regular
Avengers who are all kind of meeting
they're met with two FBI agents out of
nowhere Captain Marvel picks up on
what's going on and realizes they're not
FBI agents he attacks them they're space
Phantoms and those guys are defeated but
what's crazy is that before they can
deal with that whole situation immortus
arrives on the scene clutching the
forever Crystal and literally starts
emanating this sort of cronal warp where
he starts wiping out everything in
existence from his point spreading in an
outward Direction he literally
obliterates the entirety of the time
stream and the universe those Avengers
the time Avengers make it out just in
time the other part of this is that the
actions of immortus are also impacting
the 19th century where the other time
Avengers are out so they end up bailing
out of there as fast as they possibly
can and so at this point the only group
remaining in the timeline that they had
arrived at is Captain America and the
present-day Hank Pym and so what they
end up doing is actually traveling with
black panther to the remnants of wakanda
which has long since been a destroyed
State and what what ends up happening is
Black Panther literally says because of
the fact that these Alien Invaders are
so incredibly Advanced and our ability
to chase after them following their
defeat is non-existent because our
planet doesn't have any sort of space
travel technology anymore he says we can
literally grab what's left of the
vibranium in wakanda and we can retrofit
some vessels and then basically go after
the Martians themselves the problem here
is that when they get there because of
the manipulations of immortus there's an
entire race that operates within the
Subterranean Realm right under wakanda
down in the great Mound that feeds off
the vibranium there so to take what's
left of the vibranium would wipe out
that entire race and so that is a point
where now black panther at the behest of
Captain America has to make a choice
Captain America's stance is either you
can take what's left of this vibranium
and you can wipe out this entire race
and hope the ships that you retrofit
will lead to you being able to launch an
attack on the Martians and Destroy them
so they can never come back to earth or
you can leave this vibranium here you
can let this race continue on you can
hope the Martians never come back and
you can start rebuilding Earth which one
is it going to be ultimately black
panther ends up choosing to leave the
race alone to let them stay within the
Subterranean realm of wakanda feeding
off the vibranium and then to try to
rebuild the surface World hoping
everything can go back to normal the
cool thing here is that at this point in
time you haven't really seen immortus
making his move in the 21st century he
hasn't arrived here yet in order to do
anything and so what this does is it
leads to Captain America and his guys
basically heading back using their
chronal vessel to the Sphinx and then
reuniting with the rest of the Avengers
and so what ends up happening here is
with the Avengers completely reunited
but realizing that immortus is traveling
through the time stream and wiping out
entire universes the only thing that
they can do is actually head directly to
limbo and to try to fight him head off
what's really crazy about all of this is
this is just the surface stuff right
like the whole scheme of immortus is
much much bigger than what's going on at
least what we've initially been led to
believe that what we're talking about
here is the presumed destruction and
Recreation of the entirety of the
Multiverse in Marvel Comics
what's going on guys this is Rob and at
the end of this video you guys are gonna
have a perfect understanding of how like
Kane the Conqueror immortus how all that
stuff works together and like I said in
the previous video that we did this is
basically going to be the plot mostly to
Avengers Kane Dynasty although I would
argue Secret Wars may very well have
some plot points from this we won't
fully know until we get closer and more
information comes out but as we covered
in the previous video that what you had
were these time displaced Avengers that
have been brought together by Rick Jones
now remember while Rick Jones himself is
not the main focus of Avengers forever
the bigger Focus here is what Rick Jones
represents which is the destiny force
that in Marvel Comics over the years you
had situations where by whatever Manner
and whatever means Humanity would
somehow defy the odds and come out on
top with this kind of human just
Ingenuity or just this desire to win or
something along those lines and what
Marvel established really Kurt Busick
with Avengers forever is that it's not
simply that humanity is really has the
desire to come out on top
because sometimes the desire to win just
isn't good enough a really good example
of this is look at the Philadelphia
Eagles they really wanted to win and
they lost the Super Bowl anyway so the
thing about this is that I probably
should have said that I've pissed off
every single fan in Philadelphia
[Laughter]
I'm sorry guys but I had to so here's
the thing the destiny force is kind of
this idea that different human beings
really the human race in general has a
kind of innate energy about them they
can sort of tap into and what we'll talk
about over the course of this is exactly
how that plays out but the long and
short is that this time displaced group
of Avengers has been kind of playing
like a cat and mouse game with a mortise
trying to find him trying to stop him
and a mortis has always eluded them
virtually every step of the way because
he's a master of time and so once they
all consolidate their forces they make
the decision that instead of jumping
from one Universe to the next trying to
find immortus they head straight to his
base of operations and so when they get
there they basically get to What's
called the Nexus of time now for those
of you guys coming from X-Men the
Animated Series if you remember the
four-part episode Beyond Good and Evil
where apocalypse ends up in the Nexus
the reality and you have that custodian
guy who's red-haired he's really really
weird and then he turns into a guy who
looks like Doctor Strange at the end of
the at the end of the series that was a
mortise and this is where they were at
from here you can literally enter in and
out of any Universe in existence across
the whole Multiverse and so as they make
their way through here they find
themselves kind of caught in like
Penrose steps and different things like
that where it's really mind-boggling
because they walk up some stairs and
then find themselves walking upside down
or it looks like everybody else is
upside down it defies the laws of
physics by every standard of measurement
and so where it really kind of takes
them off guard what they find is that
they all all end up in their own
individual prisons of sorts now not
everybody's story is unique here but
what is unique is actually Captain
America coming across Nick Fury now this
is not the Nick Fury that you know and
again this is not really a Nick Fury per
se it's more of immortal is just kind of
toying with them to a degree you'll
probably see something like this in cane
Dynasty right there's a very high
likelihood and I would even argue you'll
probably see something like this in
Quantum Mania not entirely sure that's
the case but I would bet that there's a
possibility that this will happen but
the thing about this is that this
version of Nick Fury is the old school
version and the reason why Captain
America is familiar with Nick Fury
during this point in time is because in
Marvel Comics you basically had Nick
Fury and his Howling Commandos now that
was a comic book line that goes way back
to the 1970s it's been around for a long
long time but the idea with Nick Fury is
that before he became the Agent of
Shield that we're all familiar with he
was literally just a guy in the military
he was Sergeant Fury and what ended up
happening is that Sergeant Fury and the
Howling Commandos were tasked with going
to Germany and grabbing a scientist who
was developing a super soldier serum
that was of course Abraham Erskine they
successfully got him out of Germany they
extracted him from what was basically
Hydra they brought him here to the
states and then he gave the super
soldier serum to Steve Rogers so Nick
Fury has a very important history in
terms of Captain America becoming
Captain America but again at this point
in time when Steve Rogers when him
knowing who Nick Fury is it's because at
this point in time Nick Fury was a
soldier during World War II it's not
until you get to the 1960s that he
becomes an agent of shield now the
reason why he maintained his longevity
is because he ingested something called
The Infinity formula which basically
allowed him to stay youthful for an
exceedingly long amount of time
eventually he lost it in original sin
and then just became an old man or it
lost at some point along the line up to
Original Sin but of course Captain
America as we talked about in the
previous video this is a version of
Captain America that's plucked from his
own timeline or from the the Marvel
Universe at a time when Captain America
was becoming disillusioned and so that's
why this conversation between him and
Nick Fury fills Captain America with a
new level of resolve and a desire to
save the other members of The Avengers
and then go forward and confront
immortus now everybody else gets their
own kind of story lines to a degree and
they're interesting they're not really
overly important none of it really
matters the only one that does matter
here though is the events involving
Yellow Jacket because remember you've
got two versions of Pim here you've got
the Hank Pym which I call Hank Pym
classic in Avengers forever he's one of
the founding members of The Avengers
with Jana Van Dyne then you've got crazy
Hank Pym he's the one that like lost his
mind and he was going through all these
existential crises just all that kind of
stuff right just like the nuts Hank Pimp
Like that's what we're talking about and
so it's one of those cool moments where
once the team basically reconsolidates
they get back to their normal selves you
end up finding the classic Hank Pym
realizing that he'll eventually become
the crazy Hank Pym ends up allying
himself with a mortise and the reason
why is because amortis proposed this
idea that if he allies himself with
immortus that he can actually ensure a
timeline comes to existence where Hing
Pim doesn't go crazy he doesn't end up
becoming his just kind of nuts
existential madman self and so in effect
one of the members of The Avengers team
have now defected to the side of
immortus and so following this we we get
a bit of an exposition here and the
reason why is because the Avengers start
to realize that one of the space
Phantoms is masquerading as one of their
own and when The Jig Is up right when
the when the ruse is pulled that you
basically have the space Phantom this
starts offering this huge dump of
information now this is one of the
reasons why this story is so incredibly
important because up to this point in
Marvel Comics all we knew is that Kane
the conquer was going to become a
mortise but we didn't know how we didn't
really know there were no real dots
connecting that and what few dots we got
contradicted everything else right it
was just sort of weird the way it played
out but the thing about this and what we
find out is seemingly almost every major
issue that the Avengers have run into
with immortus has all been done for a
very particular purpose one of the first
things we learned though is about the
space Phantoms themselves the space
Phantom initially was just a singular
being who was out there that the
Avengers fought at one point in time and
was kind of a Prelude to like the
arrival of immortus Tempest and that
kind of stuff what we're told here is
much like what you saw in the Loki TV
show where you have those individuals
who are quote unquote pruned by the time
various Authority and they end up
basically at the very end of time on
that planet and they're ultimately
consumed this is similar to that and in
fact the show borrowed from that the way
this works is that by whatever Manner
and whatever means individuals will end
up in the realm of limbo they'll end up
in basically the place where immortus
resides sometimes they stumble into it
sometimes they cast magic not knowing
what they're doing they pass through the
portal they end up here sometimes they
get sent here by other people right just
whisked away to some Dimension somewhere
and that Dimension ends up being limbo
but whatever the case happens to be over
time every single one of these people
who were locked away here will
eventually lose themselves they'll
forget who they were and their own world
will forget who they were and in losing
their identity they will ultimately
become space Phantoms and that basically
explains where they come from and why
there's so many of them and so when this
huge Revelation is given to us what He
also says is that all these different
conflicts where immortus has shown up
here has all been done for One Singular
purpose The Avengers facing off against
immortus immortus showing up and
challenging different superheroes or
initiating events it's all been done for
a singular purpose and this has been
done at the behest of the timekeepers
that over the course of his existence
when ever Kang became immortus
eventually he was met by the arrival of
the timekeepers and instead of him being
lost to the effects of limbo much in the
same way that the space Phantoms were
due to the intervention of the
timekeepers and their ability to kind of
Safeguard and protect immortus that what
immortus would do is he would basically
prune timelines based on what the
timekeepers wanted so again referencing
the Loki TV show that's where these
similarities come from now their
motivation will be explained over the
course of this and it's actually pretty
nefarious but that will be explained as
time goes on the long and short of this
though is that as far as the timekeepers
are concerned he humanity is the
greatest threat that exists in the
Multiverse and the reason for this is
that at the moment right at the moment
that this comic is being written that
Humanity just has superheroes the
Fantastic Four the X-Men different
people like that that the most powerful
beings usually are confined to teams and
they protect Humanity from whatever
threats exist but because of the nature
of the destiny Force eventually Humanity
as a whole will achieve extreme levels
of power incredible levels of power
they'll be able to tap into what form
that power will take isn't fully fleshed
out here but what is fleshed out is that
with this new level of power Humanity
will take to the stars and when that
happens they'll start conquering entire
worlds and so on and basically in all
these different universes across the
Multiverse Humanity ends up becoming a
kind of conquering race and so that's
why when we did the last video at the
beginning of the story we covered that
little segment where basically The
Avengers showed up and conquered an
entire world the because that's what
happens across multiple realities and so
in order to keep that from happening or
at least on the on the surface in order
to keep that from happening the time
Keepers brought in immortus to get rid
of the timelines where that could
potentially be the case by removing
circumstances where Humanity would take
to the Stars yes different superhero
teams on earth have gone into space but
they never stay there they always come
back to earth because the manipulation
of immortus behind the scenes was
basically trying to keep humans confined
to Earth so that if they never leave
Earth they never become a threat to the
rest of the universe the idea is they
would never be able to channel the
destiny force in an effective way and so
again it's a it's a really cruel
Revelation here because it just talks
about these extreme manipulations and
they're far-reaching right it's one of
the reasons why his character is so
significant at Marvel but it also really
shows how in just how immensely powerful
he is and that's something that I hope
we take away from this because if the
Marvel Cinematic Universe handles Kane
the Conqueror right he'll be
ridiculously op not by just physical
strength or the ability to shoot energy
or something like that but because how
do you stop a guy who can prevent you
from being born or who could have your
have some situation where like you're
Switched at Birth and you're raised by a
different family and instead of becoming
an Avenger like Captain America becoming
an Avenger Captain America is the guy
who works in a tax office somewhere
right just things like that right being
able to alter the entire history of a
universe or even just using the forever
Crystal wipe an entire universe out of
existence right literally just blink it
out just with a with just like that it
ceases to exist because one of the
things to remember is that in Marvel
Comics you have Branch universe theory
that alternate realities come into
existence because something that
happened in the main Marvel Universe
happened differently right a really good
example of this is in secret Wars in
1984. Peter Parker gets the Venom
symbiote for the very first time it's
not called the Venom symbiote but it
becomes the Venom symbiote so there's an
alternate reality out there where Peter
never lost it and in fact there is a
story where that happens and the
Symbiote basically just consumes him
there's a point where the Symbiotes
blown off of his body and it's just
literally bones like it had literally
eaten his physical body and so it's just
the Symbiote walking around bones it's
pretty gruesome and it's pretty messed
up but that's an alternate reality now
right what if this one thing had
happened different now it's an alternate
universe so all in mortis has to do is
go back to that moment when things
deviated when that Branch happened and
keep that event from taking place or
just wipe the universe out entirely
there's any number of ways that he can
pull that off but that's what he's been
doing over the course of time is working
for the time Keepers by basically
pruning entire timelines but the problem
with this is that seemingly The Avengers
always end up finding a way to train or
to to transition into space and Humanity
seems to always find a way to attain the
destiny force and so what ends up
happening is that with immortus and
yellow jacket working together
Yellowjackets subdues The Avengers and
then when they wake up they base
basically find themselves in an
alternate reality and that's one of the
things to know when you're facing off
against someone like immortus that in
you know instead of like it being a
normal circumstance like here right you
get kidnapped and they drop you off in a
field somewhere that you get kidnapped
and you get dropped off three universes
over right that's what you end up with
that's why I'm messing with somebody
like like immortus or even King is such
a dangerous thing because you could just
be thrown into the Multiverse and you'll
never make your way back you'll never
get back to your home Universe it's like
sliders right it's like that TV show
sliders but when the Avengers wake up
they kind of wake up in this different
reality where again you have these kind
of Ironclad Avengers who operate as like
conquerors but what ends up happening
and it's a quick realization these you
know kind of uh nights nightly Avengers
if you want to call them that they don't
see the real Avengers as actual Avengers
they see them as the Guardians of the
Galaxy now here's the thing in Marvel
Comics kind of a quick aside here in
Marvel Comics The Guardians of the
Galaxy as you know them now which is
like Peter Quill and like Rocket Raccoon
and Groot and Gamora and all those guys
that's not the original Guardians the
original Guardians of the Galaxy were
called the Guardians of the Galaxy 3000.
they literally came from the 31st
Century but this is that team right this
is like the original Guardians of the
Galaxy 3000 team they were at least
they're seen as Freedom Fighters here
individuals who are fighting against the
Conquering nature of the Avengers and
it's why they're immediately attacked
now in the midst of all this basically
Hank Pym or at least yellowjack and Hank
Pym steps in and basically helps them to
overcome these enemies and then reveals
to them that the reason why they appear
different was because of things called
Limbo bugs which basically kind of cast
an illusion and make things seem
different than they actually are but the
important thing here is that this allows
the Avengers to be taken prisoner and to
actually be brought directly in front of
the timekeepers themselves by immortus
and this is a de facto trial that's
really all this is that is the time
Keepers speaking directly to the
Avengers as basically immortus watches
on and this is when we get this really
really cool Revelation here right this
really cool explanation there is a bit
of discussion here in the sense that
what you had was being called he who
remains at the very end of time and in
order to ensure the preservation of the
time stream he created the timekeepers
in order to ensure that time flowed as
it was supposed to that all reality
functioned the way it was supposed to
and the the coming of the new universe
right because that Universe was
effectively ending but even the
timekeepers themselves appear to be
nefarious foes and the reason for this
is because over the course of this trial
and in this conversation that they have
what the timekeepers say is exactly what
we just talked about they taxed immortus
with wiping out different timelines
where the Avengers would transition to
the Stars harness the power of the
destiny force and become conquerors and
so in realizing this what they decide is
to basically Purge any and all of those
realities that exist out there and in
fact every every world or every version
of Earth across the Multiverse will
effectively be put on lockdown where
humans would never be allowed to leave
Earth they would be forced to stay there
now again the question of the Avengers
is but like why though because at the
end of the day like we as The Avengers
like we're good guys we're superheroes
we would never become villains and there
really isn't even anything for us to for
you to worry about when it comes to us
because there are groups and individuals
out there that are more powerful than us
on Earth but the response to the
timekeepers is you underestimate your
level of power right think about it of
all the planets that exist in any one
universe and particularly in your main
Marvel Universe Earth is the only world
that was able to Stave off Galactus that
was able to hold Galactus back and in
fact send him running in fear when like
Reed Richards ran up on him brandishing
the ultimate nullifier right like
Humanity has managed to hold off the
Judgment of the celestials it's one of
these things where they're basically
making this argument humanity is way way
more powerful than you think it is and
it's only a matter of time before this
Destiny force will be harnessed by
humanity and they'll basically destroy
everything in existence or at least
conquer entire universes and so when the
questions asked by Captain America how
in how many universes does this take
place and the response of the
timekeepers is it happens 42 percent of
the time and that's when The Avengers
are like that's stupid man so like you
literally want to punish the entirety of
humanity across the Multiverse confining
us to Earth so we can never leave over
the fact that only 42 percent of the
time we become Universal conquerors and
even if your job is to do nothing more
than observe then what does it matter
because this is the natural flow of
things arguably it's how it's supposed
to happen so that's when they call the
bluff of the timekeepers and their
argument is it has nothing to do with
Justice it has nothing to do with
maintaining the flow of time or anything
like that this is you just trying to
ensure that nobody gets in your way you
want to be be the soul beings capable of
like ruling the entire universe that's
really all you want to do it's a mad
grab for power and you're masquerading
as a PR as a group of people trying to
do the right thing trying to ensure that
different universes across the
Multiverse all stay protected yeah we
call your bluff and that's not gonna
happen now the other part of this and
the big Revelation that goes on here is
yellowjacket classic Hank Pym that what
had happened here is that him working
alongside immortus it was not a ruse he
really intended to betray The Avengers
but when he realized what was going on
with Immortals of the timekeepers which
is to say that the 42 percent right
those universes that exist out there
where Humanity would end up becoming
conquerors that the timekeepers wanted
to wipe those universes out that the
desire or at least the intention of uh
of yellowjacket right classic hang Pim
what's the turn against both immortus
and the timekeepers one that's the
reason why he was we freed the Avengers
in the first place and two that's why he
called for backup when he realized lies
what was happening he sent out an SOS
now this SOS comes in two forms the
first is Rick Jones and Kang the
Conqueror alongside the Supreme
intelligence now here's the cool thing
about this Kane the Conqueror arriving
on the scene is no small thing because
Kang is inevitably destined to become
immortus but what you're talking about
here are two guys who are able to
manipulate the timeline now which one is
more powerful is one of the most debated
things in Marvel Comics like that debate
rages across the fandom it just goes on
and on and on and on and I don't think
we'll ever definitively get an answer to
that unless Marvel creates one but the
reality here is that with Kane the
conquer stepping in The Avengers freed
Rick Jones being able to harness the
power of the destiny force and the
Supreme intelligence just sitting there
as a giant head in a jar watching it all
in full that the uh the timekeepers
basically summon their own teams and so
what you end up getting is basically the
quote unquote evil Avengers from across
the time stream all these different evil
Avengers that you see or that we have
seen showing up here and facing off
against the good Avengers and so in
response to that the good Avengers
summoned their own backup which is
basically every version or every every
avenger that exists in the Multiverse
literally coming in right every single
good guy showing up to face off every
single bad guy and that's why I say this
is probably what you're going to see in
King Dynasty that in King Dynasty and
Secret Wars you're going to see a whole
host of evil Avengers it's gonna be
amazing right it's gonna be ridiculously
cool just like like Avengers from the
Multiverse all fighting against each
other right just a giant thing that's
why it's gonna be called secret War
because it's going to happen all the way
out there and the average person is
going to have no idea that it's taking
place but in the midst of all this
immortus realizing that what the
timekeepers would do is not only
eradicate The Avengers who were here but
even go so far as to just prune entire
universes can't tolerate anymore he
can't side with this anymore so in fact
he even he ends up taking the crystal
the forever Crystal and tries to hide it
from the timekeepers Turning against
them refusing to let them destroy the
Avengers and a lot of this is because
with immortus having watched The
Avengers for so long having guided their
actions he almost sees them as his own
children but he almost feels very much
like a parent he's come to care about
them and come to love them even though
what he was doing was a manipulation
behind the scenes and so when he turns
against the timekeepers the timekeepers
eradicate him on the spot they literally
destroy him and like that's basically it
and so in the midst of this giant
conflict between all these different
Avengers ultimately the good guys
effectively come out on top now it's not
for the time Keepers stepping in and
like freezing everything in place but
with Kane the Conqueror being a guy who
is literally protected from the time
stream and the impact of time remember
you can't freeze Kane the Conqueror in
place in time it doesn't work that way
he's a master of Tom all he has to do is
just kind of like not he's just not the
affected by it because at all times his
suit of armor allows him to operate in
flux right it allows him to exist kind
of outside the current effects of time
and so this is the reason why even when
the the timekeepers basically frees
everybody in place by manipulating time
Kane the Conqueror is not affected but
realizing the the power of King and
realizing that he's like the last
missing piece the last person that can
manipulate the time stream and truly
stand in their way the timekeepers try
to basically turn Kang into a mortise
but what ends up happening is that with
that version of immortus having been
destroyed this is where the cleanup Duty
comes into play that what Marvel does
now is they say actually immortus as he
exists from this point going forward is
the result of the timekeepers trying to
turn Kang into a mortise while literally
speeding up his Evolution and then in
turn came to conqueror resisting and so
what is what's really told here is that
in this effort to transform Kang that
you end up getting this it's almost kind
of squelching sound right this tearing
sound like flesh is ripped and came to
conqueror himself remains his normal
self the issue with this is that even
though the timekeepers are trying to use
this forever Crystal to literally
obliterate entire timelines by using its
energy to fire a cannon that because
they're so weakened now after having
tried to force Kang into becoming
immortus that ultimately King takes that
moment to kill the timekeepers he
literally eradicates them on the spot
and so once the battle is concluded
Captain America who now has possession
of the crystal ends up destroying it and
that witness destroyed everybody starts
blinking back to their own individual
timelines right they start going back to
where they're supposed to be and so you
have this really really interesting
moment here where you basically have the
rise of the new immortus right literally
this immortus pops up here as having
been kind of pulled away from Kane to
conquer so in essence King and immortus
are the exact same person that's the
reason why now in Marvel Comics you
don't really see much discussion about
immortus being the person the king will
become instead it's immortus referring
to Kang as being a mortise and it's Kang
referring to immortus as being Kang
because literally they're ripped out of
the same person because literally what
had happened here is in an attempt to
turn Kang into a mortise Kang resisted
and so that immortus aspect of him was
pulled away it's not that dissimilar to
Eve being made from the Flesh of Adam
right they're very similar things in
that way but the long and short of this
is that with that Crystal destroyed
everybody blinking back to their normal
points in time what we're told here is
that the crystal represents a concept it
represents the idea of being able to
manipulate and control time and so what
the crystal represents can never truly
be destroyed all it really did is
destroy the physical form or the object
that houses the power of the Crystal and
so that powers kind of disincorporated
and it's out there but we're basically
told at some future point in time it'll
reform and it'll appear when it needs to
so it's really just kind of Marvel
saying like you'll see this kind of
thing happen right it's like Battlestar
Galactica all this has happened before
and all of it will happen again but
again that's the nature of the Avengers
forever story is it's basically cleaning
up the continuity of Kang and immortus
Scarlet Centurion iron lad Rama Tut all
that kind of stuff all those different
versions of Kane the Conqueror that
we've seen over the years it's clearing
all that stuff up while at the same time
giving us a pretty interesting and
compelling story but once everything
settles down and once everybody starts
blinking Back The Avengers more or less
say their goodbyes because they all just
kind of go back to their own individual
timelines and the story effectively ends
there but again this is why I say like
this is going to be the storyline that
you see in like Kane Kane Dynasty and
probably Avengers Secret Wars I'm like
99 sure this is what's gonna happen but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace